Zoomed down to the chromosomal level, I hope you
have a new appreciation for what the human genome
really is. We've zoomed all the way in and
looked at double-stranded DNA, naked by itself. But inside
a cell, DNA is almost always wrapped around histone
proteins and organized into a higher order structure called
a chromosome. And chromosomes are pretty much what we've
been dealing with for the last couple of exercises.
>> Okay. Now, let me try if I have
this right.
>> Okay.
>> My genome, that's inside of one of my cells is made up of 2 copies of 3
Billion base pairs of letters? That are organized into 23 pairs of chromosomes?
>> That's exactly right. Almost.
>> I thought I had it.
>> You did, but I've left out one tiny detail. Actually there's more DNA than
just the 23 pairs of chromosomes in the nucleus. There's a little bit of DNA,
actually outside in the cytoplasm of the
cell, inside another organelle and scientists have figured
out that this organelle that has its own
DNA. Used to be its own free-living bacteria.
>> Okay, but what's an organelle again?
>> Well, an organelle is just kind of like
an organ for a cell. They're membrane-bound structures that
perform particular functions inside a cell. So take a
look at this picture of a cell here. What
I want to see if you can do is
look this picture and pick out which organelle you think
has its own set of DNA. Now, this could be
a little difficult if you don't have a background or
know wher to look, but remember that this organelle
used to be it's own free living bacteria. And, bacteria
look like this. So, do you best and see if
you can figure out which organelle has it's own DNA.